[Music]
basketball is usually a very dynamic
sport but there comes a point in every
game when everything comes to a
standstill right here at the foul line
for a free throw it's not a terribly
difficult shot
there's nobody guarding you you've got
10 seconds to aim and shoot the very
best have career averages of around 90%
that's over the course of thousands of
efficient games look at that number go
up today we're gonna look at why
averaging 95 percent from the foul line
is almost impossible to find out what it
takes I shot with one of the most
consistent free-throw shooters of all
time
I talked to shot science with a
dynamicists when you run these kinds of
simulations you notice that there's an
optimum angle which is actually the
least effort angle and spoke with a
cognitive scientist about why even the
best choke under pressure you can
perform more poorly than expected
precisely because people are watching
you or there's something on the line the
free-throw has been the same for decades
it's 15 feet from the line to the basket
which is a standard 10 feet off the
ground
the average free-throw percentage for
the NBA WNBA and n-c-double-a hovers
around 70% but there are those players
who can sync it time after time barely
ever missing the very best have career
averages of around 90% this player is
one of them so we're here with Steve
Nash Steve is obviously a very talented
basketball player I am not right you've
shot a ball a few times I did it for a
long time over the course of his career
Nash toed the foul line 3384 times and
sake the ball 3060 of those
his career record is the highest of any
retired pro at ninety point four three
percents he's gonna help us work on our
free-throw technique and see if we can't
get a little better and also talked with
us about what we think the upper limit
to free-throw accuracy might be and I'm
gonna kick his ass off of that so
kicking my ass was not going to be
difficult I barely touched the
basketball in twenty years and I was
rusty at the line Nash gave me some
pointers on how to shoot with my whole
body okay let's try a few where you slow
down a little bit you start at the
bottom and you come up and shoot it all
in one motion so your body comes up with
the ball and the ball releases before or
at the end of that motion Nash showed me
his technique for better shooting you
know I try to take all the extra
movements out of it right and it's just
one smooth one motion
yeah there's no strain there's no
forcing there's no flicking at the rim
it's a really smooth stroke that makes
sense yeah so this gonna sound like a
dumb question but why why can't people
get free throws all the time for exactly
the reasons that uh you know the best
free-throw shooters make them you know
they they probably don't have the great
have the best technique they probably
don't take the most pride in it or
practice it as diligently as they should
and I think
and then lastly some people emotionally
especially if you haven't done the work
it's gonna affect your technique more
right one of the reasons Nash was so
successful was that he did the work and
he took pride in the shot and he
practiced a lot when I was younger I
would shoot a lot of them when I got
older it was just refining sometimes
would be like ten for practice ten after
practice ten before the game you know or
maybe just a couple and just to refine
it get in that moment reproducibility
he's
to demonstrate why Nash and I each shot
a series of free-throws you can see here
Nash had no problem sinking ball after
ball after ball I on the other hand was
throwing up bricks lots of them now I
have given me great pointers on how to
perfect my technique but I wanted to
know if the free throw could be scienced
into submission for joining us so I
called up Larry Silverberg I'm a
professor here at NC State I'm a
dynamicists that means I study motion
and I spend a lot of my time probably
more time than I really should studying
the motion of basketball Silverberg has
written a number of papers on the
physics of the free throw to him it's an
elegant problem
it's a beautiful experiment no but
you're not moving you can just walk up
to the line it's the same for every
single player so you can actually look
at the shot very scientific what he's
found is that players like Nash
incorporate four key parameters into
their free-throw first and foremost is
the initial velocity of the ball the
second thing is you have to line up the
ball that balls got to go directly
toward the center of the hoop that
second factor is called side angle you
want to keep it as small as possible to
make the ball go straight the third
parameter is a bit of backspin the
backspin is very important it makes the
ball land on the basket a little bit
softer and at more of a chance of the
ball of the ball going in and then
there's the ball's arc which depends on
your release angle when you run these
kinds of simulations you notice that
there's an optimum angle which is
actually the least effort angle that
tends to be a release angle of about
depending on your height of anywhere
between 45 46 and 53 degrees so not many
players could tell you what their
release angle is but that may be
changing well nation' I thought we use
an app he's helped develop called
homecourt which uses an artificial
intelligence to track and analyze
basketball shots the app just released a
new feature that measures not only your
makes and misses of the line but other
metrics like release angle our app is
called home court a is a piece of
technology artificial intelligence
and track not only your body movement
but also the flight of your ball makes
mrs. arc release time angle all those
things so you were nine or thirty oh
just thirty percent your best streak was
two in a row it's really hard to be a
great free-throw shooter 200 we got to
get you three four five get some
momentum some confidence
how did Nash do accuracy hundred percent
thirty four to thirty four best streak
was 34 your range is only four degrees
yes so that means that the biggest
difference you ever saw in your release
angle was just four degrees and mine was
twenty yeah I mean that tells a lot
right I mean obviously so this is I mean
this is such a great tool makes and
misses is only one part of the equation
like but if I can see like the variance
in your release angle is like wild right
here we have a problem
if I can see that it's tightening up but
you're not necessarily getting better
I still feel positive like there's a
breakthrough coming now before Nash had
arrived I had actually shot just over
50% but shooting with one of the world's
greatest point guards is a little
intimidating as soon as he showed up my
percentage dropped by 20% I talk about
it as paralysis by analysis you start
paying too much to the details of what
you're doing in a way that's
counterproductive
that's Seon by Locke I'm a cognitive
scientist and I'm president of Barnard
College at Columbia University and I am
an expert in why we choke under pressure
and what to do about it
pressure can affect the pros too Nash
took well over a hundred free throws
with us
he said that was more than he'd taken
since he retired in 2015 and of Loony
shots
he missed - it's been a while for me too
but that's greater than 98 percent
accuracy and yet over the course of his
career he averaged closer to 90 percent
and that's because performing in a game
is way different from performing
in practice what we often forget is that
it's important to close this gap between
training and competition and what I mean
by that is practicing under the kinds of
conditions you're gonna perform under I
think we've all had the experience where
we can hit that shot when no one's
watching or 50% of our free throws when
no one's there
but when all eyes are on us we fumble
and so the idea is to get used to how
we're gonna feel how our body is gonna
react in that moment if we're gonna have
important people come to an event like
our parents watching us play basketball
make sure that they're there during
practice at some point too so we're not
all of a sudden entering a new situation
when it matters most the free throw if
you've done all your homework and you
have the right technique
it becomes an ability to believe and to
cut out all the distractions and put
yourself back on the practice court in
the heart of a big moment to make the
most of his shot Nash was always
practicing even during games before the
referee gave me the ball I would take
two if I could practice shots without
the ball that's like a rehearsal yeah
right so that I just got to practice
shots in before I shot the ball all
right you know I think sports
psychologists say now that even better
than visualization is actual physical
recreation you know even without the
ball clearly I needed to practice so I
took home court with me to my local
court and shot and shot and shot could I
improve could an amateur like me ever
achieve NBA level accuracy well this guy
as all things become good it was three
things knowledge practice and time this
is Bob Fisher I'm like a million guys I
played high school basketball I played
recreationally to us 44 and quit because
young guys like you just got to quit
except at about ten years ago
Fisher really started practicing free
throws and in September of oh nine I
went to the gym and started going the
gym every day after a month I noticed I
was getting concerned better and then I
started making a hundred every day in a
row and then I switched over to speed
and January four months later January
10th I set my first record most in a
minute today he has 25 Guinness World
Records most in 30 seconds with 33 most
in a minute with 52 most in two minutes
with 92 most in 10 minutes with 148 you
get the idea Fisher a longtime coach has
so written the book and made an
instructional video on how to shoot more
accurately if you focus on the high
point of the ball and apply force
control the high point of the ball and
rights and shift in the center of the
basket it's gonna go straight fissure is
no NBA legend but its free-throw
percentage I made 99 out of that so if a
guy like Fischer can sink the ball 99%
of the time I should be able to put it
in the basket a little more often right
now might be a good time to mention that
there's another way to shoot from the
line and that's underhanded one of the
best practitioners of this technique was
Rick Barry over the course of his career
he averaged eighty nine point three one
percent from the line Rick Barry is
obviously one of our all-time great
players and was unbelievable from the
foul line
underhand he swears that it's it's bet
it's wiser to shoot him on your hand
let's just say it has its trade-offs
what happens in the underhand shot is
the body motion is very very smooth it's
inherently smooth there's just a single
motion from the from down low all the
way up high that can be committed to
memory I think pretty easily so it's
easy to perfect on the other hand you do
have a disadvantage because you're
releasing the ball low so you have this
trade-off between releasing the ball low
and having smooth body motion the smooth
body motion means that you can become
much more consistent at it I think
there's something about the ball
starting down here and ending up there
that feels more awkward than finishing
above your head I could see how it would
limit some of the kind of extraneous and
unnecessary movements that creep in from
time to time I'm gonna stick with the
overhand in a week of shooting with home
court tracking and analyzing my shots I
managed to increase my free-throw
percentage from around 30 percent to 75
percent in my release angle went from
varying by more than 20 degrees to
varying by less than 8 so I got better
but what about the pros with better
practice and preparation could the pros
edge the record even higher it turns out
Steph Curry recently surpassed Nash's
record but only by a couple hundredths
of a percent the NBA in particular is an
incredible demand
I think you're traveling changing time
zones playing you know three and a half
three games a week you know you may be
carrying an injury and so to corral all
these factors is why we don't see
someone shooting high 90s or a hundred
percent right now is there gonna be some
outlier that comes along why not I mean
it's actually remarkable to me that
Steph isn't more of an outlier the real
outlier is Elena Delle Donne who plays
for the WNBA's Washington Mystics her
career free-throw percentage is a
monstrous ninety three point four
percent but remember neither she nor
curry has retired yet so those records
aren't set in stone you know so many
games are decided the free-throw line
today it's very possible that as we
become more sophisticated more
technological that a shift could take
place where some coaches might start to
actually pay attention to the free-throw
but until that happens remember that
what players like Nash do with the line
time after time after time is already
almost impossible
[Music]
good